para analizar este y otros temas
relacionados con fútbol le damos en la
bienvenida a Sara Castro directora del
diario as Colombia y directora de
deportes en Caracol radio bienvenida
Sara Buenas noches Luis como siempre Un
gusto Sara Tenemos que hablar Qué
significa esta salida de Karim Benzema
cuando le restaba un año de contrato y
Qué impacto Podría tener en el Real
Madrid después si bien no es un retiro
un retiro oficial si estamos hablando de
una despedida de la élite y cuando uno
habla de Karim Benzema está hablando de
un nueve que no es solo un nueve es un 9
con unos registros dentro de un marco de
calidad que son irrebatibles y sobre
todo Yo diría que
indescifrables yo creo que es un 9 en el
que sus rivales nunca sabían que esperar
de él y no está mal decir que la
Champions del 2022 del Real Madrid de su
Champions no Porque estemos olvidando
que el fútbol es un deporte colectivo
sino porque él no solo dio
demostraciones de una calidad enorme de
un talento se puso un poco llevó al
hombro el sino que los hizo jugar mejor
hay mucha gente que dice que es un
consentido de Florentino Pérez pero yo
creo que él supo esperar su momento
estuvo a la sombra de Cristiano Ronaldo
durante sus años Gloriosos en el Real
Madrid pero cuando Cristiano Ronaldo se
va a la Juventus él da un paso al frente
y se convierte en ese jugador referente
que necesitaba el equipo ahora lo
mencionabas bien llegó hace 14 años
consiguió 25 títulos cinco Champions
League Así que reemplazarlo va a ser muy
difícil y creo que aquí es donde
empezamos a hablar de la planificación
de deportiva del Real Madrid que tendrá
que armar su ataque ya hemos sabido de
la salida de Mariano de hazard de
asensio que si bien no eran tan
fundamentales en este equipo de
ancelotti pues dejan un vacío grande
esperan recuperar a abrahim y a joselu
Pero dónde viene ese gran nueve que
puede ser el que puede cargar la presión
de ser el centro delantero del Real
Madrid se habla de Harry kane se habla
de haberts pero hasta ahora nada
concreto y tener
a Benzema en la plantilla si bien no
estaba en su Prime no estaba en esa
misma temporada que hizo en el 21 22
creo que le daba mucha estabilidad al
equipo en cuanto a contrataciones creo
que en este mercado tendrá que moverse
al Real Madrid y sobre todo con mucho
cuidado después de lo que le pasó con
Eder hablamos de fútbol femenino porque
ayer el Barcelona consiguió el título de
la Champions League femenina un título
que alcanzan luego de caer en la final
del año pasado frente al Olympique de
Lyon Qué significa para el Fútbol Club
Barcelona alzar esta copa precisamente
luego de no poder en años anteriores
conseguir Este título Yo creo que el
Barcelona demostró que en el fútbol Nada
es casualidad Y tanto indhoven como
todas las personas que vieron el partido
alrededor del mundo se dieron cuenta de
esto Al final a pesar de los tropiezos
Incluso en ese partido empiezan
perdiendo dos cero y la caída que ya
mencionadas del año pasado
lo que demuestra esto que con inversión
y un proyecto deportivo claro es posible
conseguir cosas Este ha sido un equipo
que si bien desde el 70 ha tenido
divisiones femeninas Solo hasta el 2002
lo hace oficial y hasta el 2015 lo hace
profesional es decir que estamos
hablando de un periodo de tiempo muy
corto pero que en el que sí decidieron
competir en Europa esta ha sido una
temporada de más en donde no han podido
contar con su gran referente Alexia
putellas pero tienen jugadoras de
grandísima valía Sandra paños en el arco
eh
Como delantera Hay muchísimo talento
pero sobre todo de la convicción en que
el fútbol femenino tiene futuro tiene
una cabida en la industria y esto se ha
notado ahí yo creo que es más que
merecido empiezan a reinar en Europa y
sin duda ligas como la francesa ligas
como la inglesa que también han
demostrado este interés se pondrán muy
al día para poder seguir digamos en esa
lucha por ser las reinas de Europa ahora
por otro lado también ayer el Manchester
City se quedó con la un torneo de
importancia
dentro de el fútbol inglés que vale Este
título para el Manchester City sobre
todo que estamos hablando
de la previa a lo que va a ser la final
de la Champions League me gustó mucho un
mensaje que vi de gundogan que creo que
fue uno de los de los grandes no solo
figuras de esta temporada sino de ese
partido él decía que era una copa local
de muchísimas relevancia y es importante
que este equipo mantenga la atención
competitiva a pesar de esa superioridad
que ha mostrado tanto en la Premier y
sobre todo esa clasificación tan
importante a la final de la Champions
entonces creo que hemos redundado en
todo lo que ha conseguido este equipo un
equipo que ha
cambiado su forma de jugar se ha
adaptado pero sobre toda redoblado
apuestas en momentos fundamentales lo de
Pep Guardiola es histórico y ya dentro
de ocho días estaremos analizando esta
final de la Champions League pero creo
que esto también nos lleva a pensar en
un Manchester United que contenga tuvo
un comienzo difícil desde los resultados
del juego pero que ha logrado clasificar
a la Champions League fundamental muchos
de los grandes quedaron fuera ganó la
caravacao que es otra de las copas
internas que me parece que le dan un
poco de juego y lo que empieza aquí es
un digamos Yo creo que el juego ya ha
empezado a demostrar cuál es esa línea
Cuál es ese modelo esa idea Pero va a
empezar a hacer una selección de los
jugadores que él quiere creo que entrará
en algunas disputas con las directivas
sobre estas transferencias a mitad de
año pero siento que el Manchester United
tiene también un proceso encaminado
Muchísimas gracias Sara por este amplio
análisis respecto al fútbol un gusto